beweist ein neues video die unschuld des
erschossenen afro amerikaners dijon gysi
der 29 jährige war am dienstag in los
angeles auf seinem fahrrad wegen
verstoßes gegen eine verkehrsregel von
polizisten angehalten worden
bei der kontrolle habe er während einer
rangelei einem polizisten ins gesicht
geschlagen bevor er davonlief
laut polizei sei ihnen dabei eine
halbautomatische handfeuerwaffe
heruntergefallen nach der die john key
sie greifen wollte daraufhin eröffneten
die polizisten das tödliche feuer auf
ihn
laut augenzeugen mindestens 20 schuss es
gibt jetzt neue schockierende videos wie
die polizisten zahlreiche schüsse
abgefeuert haben einige angeblich noch
als die chance bereits am boden gelegen
ist
so sieht es jedenfalls die familie und
auch viele augenzeugen
sie haben einfach geschossen geschossen
geschossen völlig unklar wieso denn er
lag schon längst am boden
ich habe den cops gesagt schießt nur um
zu töten
selbst wenn es in dieser situation etwas
gegeben hätte was euch gedroht hätte
habt ihr nicht das recht das ganze durch
die erschießung zu lösen die frage der
bedrohung greift auch kies anwalt beim
kramp auf er postete eines der neuen
videos welches die unschuld des 29
jährigen beweisen soll
man sieht wie sie mit einem polizisten
kämpft und sich dann zur flucht umdreht
dabei lässt er einige gegenstände aus
seiner hand fallen ob wirklich eine
waffe darunter war ist nicht erkennbar
laut ben kramp sehe man aber selbst wenn
sie eine waffe bei sich trug habe er
damit definitiv nicht auf die polizisten
gezielt sondern sich zur flucht
weggedreht die folgenden vielfachen
schüsse seien also völlig unnötig
gewesen
über dieses video möchte
sprich mit martin hofmann bei mir im
studio sie sind profiler jetzt haben wir
dieses video gerade gesehen es ist das
neueste das aufgetaucht ist und zu sehen
ist dass er wegrennt jetzt haben wir
gerade an dem beitrag auch gehört viele
stellen sich die frage warum also diese
ganzen schüsse wie sehen sie das aus
ihrer sicht was erkennt man auf diesem
video über die situation mit die szenen
die sich da abgespielt haben
das ist die anzahl der schüsse unnötig
war steht glaube ich außer zweifel wenn
jemand bereits auf dem boden liegt oder
bereits tot ist warum dann noch mehr als
zehn weitere schüsse nötig sind das
glaube ich außer frage dass das
unangemessen war aber die frage ist ja
war es überhaupt nötig zu schießen und
die frage kann ich auch anhand des
videos nicht ganz eindeutig beantworten
man muss sagen in den usa ist die waffen
dichte natürlich viel größer als in
deutschland und polizeikontrollen in den
usa sind für die kontrollierten aber
auch für die polizei
extreme stresssituation weil es gibt
immer die möglichkeit dass jemand eine
waffe dabei hat und sogenannte off ist
ein wolf shootings dass es zu einer
schiesserei oder schüssen von einer von
beiden seiten kommt ist natürlich in den
usa viel wahrscheinlicher
deswegen weiß jedes grundschulkind lernt
bereits dass man bei polizeikontrollen
in den usa selbst als kind sich ruhig
verhält immer die hände zeigt und keine
hektischen bewegungen macht denn
hektische bewegungen sind in
polizeikontrollen in den usa keine gute
idee denn die wollen auch zurück zu
ihren familien gehen die wollen auch
nicht erschossen werden und man muss
bevor man hier sagt das ist totschlag
oder mord und rassistisch motiviert
bevor man das klar sagt muss man auch
die frage stellen stellen sich vor sie
sind als blonde frau als blonde weiße
frau in amerika mit dem fahrrad mit
einer halbautomatischen waffe unterwegs
sie werden dann von der polizei
kontrolliert lassen die waffe fallen
schlagen den ins gesicht und machen eine
hektische bewegung hätte man sie auch
erschossen
ich kann die frage nicht vollkommen klar
mit nein beantworten
deswegen bin ich etwas vorsichtig das
hier sofort als fehlverhalten der
polizei und auch sofort als rassismus
hinzustellen oder oder zu definieren
in dem video sieht man eher läuft weg
und ihm wird in den rücken geschossen
aber eine wichtige frage ist noch offen
und die sieht man in dem video nicht
vollkommen klar wo lag die waffe ist er
von der waffe weg gelaufen oder ist er
eher auf die waffe zugelaufen
also lag die war für hinter ihm und er
hat sich quasi zur waffe gedreht oder
lag die waffe vor ihm und er hat sich
von der waffe weggedreht das ist ganz
entscheidend um beurteilen zu können ob
das wirklich eine bedrohungssituation
für die polizei war oder nicht
das heißt diese zwei fragen frage eins
war das fehlverhalten der polizei und
die zweite frage wenn es fehlverhalten
war wenn es totschlag oder sogar mord
war dann ist die zweite frage ob es
wirklich rassistisch motiviert war oder
ob das nicht einer weißen person
möglicherweise auch passiert wäre
ich bin vorsichtig die begriffe rassist
oder nazi zu verwenden dann überlegen
sie mal ein rassist zu sein oder
nationalsozialist das sind starke worte
und ich weiß dass manche glauben dass
ihr öfter man die worte verwendet desto
mehr sensibilisiert man für das thema
das gegenteil ist der fall man muss
rassismus vollkommen klar benennen wo er
auftritt aber es ist man es nicht gut
beraten gerade wenn man gegen rassismus
kämpft das zu schnell zu verwenden im
fall george freut das war ein
unbewaffneter schwarzer das video von
george floyd ist unerträglich und da
gibt es auch überhaupt nichts zu
rechtfertigen aber in diesem fall ist
das eine situation die auch für die
polizisten eine extremste stress
situation ist und wir sitzen gemütlich
auf dem sessel gucken uns die videos an
und sagen ach das war aber fehlverhalten
oder nicht in dieser situation ist das
auch für die polizisten eine extreme
belastung und stress situation trotzdem
sie haben jetzt george wright gerade
angesprochen jacob black jetzt auch erst
vor wenigen tagen der fall gewesen
sieben mal in den rücken geschossen
jetzt die krise und die liste geht
leider sehr sehr lange noch weiter es
sind alles schwarze männer meist männer
aber auch frauen die von polizisten mit
übelster gewalt muss man tatsächlich
sagen mit gewalt die so in dem fall
wahrscheinlich nicht gebraucht wer wäre
angegriffen worden und meisten fällen
sogar getötet worden sind was ist das
für eine gewaltspirale die jetzt also in
den usa entsteht wenn schwarze der das
gefühl haben sie können der polizei
nicht mehr vertrauen denn egal was sie
machen
die gefahr ist sehr hoch dass sie am
ende von so einem einsatz tot sind
absolut gibt es in den usa rassismus
absolut gibt es rassismus auch bei der
polizei ja und ist es ein strukturelles
problem und da sind das alles
einzelfälle ich würde schon sagen dass
man eine struktur oder ein muster
erkennt und trotzdem ist nicht jeder
fall bei dem ein schwarzer in einer
polizeikontrolle erschossen oder
verletzt wird rassismus genauso wie
nicht jede tat die syrer gegen nicht
zuhörer der deutschen
genausowenig jede tat terrorismus ist
sondern möglicherweise eine ganz normale
kneipenschlägerei die weder etwas mit
islamismus noch mit der noch mit der
herkunft zu tun hat genauso wie nicht
jede tat eines syrers gegen deutsche
terrorismus ist genauso ist auch nicht
jede tat eines weißen polizisten gegen
schwarze in verkehrskontrollen rassismus
deswegen sage ich die anzahl der schüsse
zweifelsohne dass das war nicht nötig
wenn jemand auf dem boden liegt mit dem
rücken zur polizei unbewaffnet warum man
dann so oft schießen muss das ist
natürlich nicht nötig aber die die frage
ist ja getötet haben ja eher die ersten
drei schüsse nicht die möglicherweise 17
schüsse der nachkam
das heißt die frage ist nicht ob die
anzahl der schüsse angemessen war
sondern ob es überhaupt nötig war aber
klar gibt es eine gewaltspirale
natürlich wird es auf seiten der polizei
immer hitziger weil die auch immer
schärfer angegangen werden es gibt
natürlich auch innerhalb der
demonstranten einige die dann auch die
polizei ganz offen angreifen
es schaukelt sich auf beiden seiten hoch
das heißt immer mehr leute werden auch
in polizeikontrollen immer sage ich mal
rebellischer aber man muss leider sagen
in den usa die waffen dichte das ist das
riesenproblem und eine sache muss man
auch als ursache mal benennen die
polizeiausbildung in den usa für die
klassischen sozusagen kopf auf der
straße ist nicht standardisiert ist
variiert von bundesstaat zu bundesstaat
aber ich weiß aus eigener erfahrung das
verhältnis von psychologie anteilen im
verhältnis zum schießtraining ist
ungefähr in den meisten bundesstaaten
sechs zu eins das heißt 60 stunden für
zehn psychologie stunden und die zehen
psychologie stunden werden manchmal auch
von personen durchgeführt die nicht aus
der neuen fonds mit community kommen
sondern psychologen sind und es gibt
manchmal in der polizei seminare zu
gewaltfreier kommunikation die naiv sind
und dann gehen die cops aus der aus der
vorlesung raus und sagen in welchem
universum soll das funktionieren
diese gewaltfreie kommunikation das sind
kriminelle die sind bewaffnet die am 10
kilo koks im kofferraum da ist nichts
mit
erstmals sprechen sondern da muss man
das eigene leben retten diese
einstellung merkt man leider bei der
polizei oft das liegt aber daran dass
auch teilweise diese diese seminare ein
bisschen halbherzig gemacht werden ist
eine art pflichtprogramm bisschen
gewaltfreie kommunikation man psycho
ließen extrem machtvolle waffe aber man
darf auch nicht naiv in diese situation
gehen natürlich sind das keine
unschuldslämmer und natürlich hilft da
keine
keine wie soll ich sagen da hilft kein
smalltalk um aus der situation heraus zu
kommen aber trotzdem wird psychologie
von vielen der der kopf immer noch
unterschätzt weil man kann damit vieles
lösen und auch in solchen fällen kann
man hätte man mit mit worten oder
anderen reaktionen das möglicherweise
anders lösen können als das immer leute
sterben übrigens auf beiden seiten ja
manchmal eskalieren diese situation ja
auch anders herum so dass polizisten im
dienst erschossen werden und beides kann
man verhindern indem man vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger schießtraining und
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr psychologie
oder kommunikationstraining macht das
ist eine der ursachen dass zu wenig
gesprochen und zu viel geschossen wird
ja vielen dank marco hofmann für ihre
einschätzung analyse dankeschön